at michigan state university
and
the topic of this week's presentation is
nutrient management and established
plantings
how to correct uh
future problems once
the
crop has been established so
eric
i'll send it to you
okay
happy new year everybody
it's a wonderful 46 degree sunny day in
central michigan just a typical
mid january day for us
um so what we'll be uh covering here
today is uh
approaches to
correcting nutrient problems in existing
plantings
and
we've
previous webinars have covered topics
such as the
soil characteristics and testing of
soils interpretation of the testing
and then pre-plant soil
treatments
also
plant tissue analysis and interpretation
of analysis
as well as uh
symptoms of nutritional uh problems so
uh that's great background for what
we'll
cover uh today which is uh what to do if
a
nutrient need uh is known so i'll cover
uh macronutrients uh primarily nitrogen
is the primary concern and then go
through some of the micronutrients that
can become problems in the
and then also talk a little bit about
the fertigation because i know a number
of
uh growers in different regions use
fertigation
so
let's uh
first consider nitrogen management so
this is of course important because
nearly all of these berry crops require
nitrogen on an annual uh
annual basis
uh so the the big question is what can
you do to
use nitrogen efficiently and
in that regard
there are questions about the fertilizer
type the rate the timing and the
placement of those so those are the four
items i'd like to go through for uh
under nitrogen management
first regarding the
nitrogen
fertilizers a lot of them to choose from
here i wanted to
point out generally those with
the
highest nitrogen
contents are the cheapest per pound of
nitrogen
so those are generally the most
preferred
sources and of course these also vary in
their reaction in the soil so
most of them
certainly all of them that
supply nitrogen in ammonium form or a
combination of ammonium and nitrate
tend to have an acidifying reaction in
the soil
and those that uh supply nitrogen only
as nitrate
have a a basic
reaction in the soil and
the measurement to that is called the
lime equivalent
and
that's on the far
right here
and the lime equivalent is essentially
the pounds of lime that would be
equivalent in reaction to one pound of
nitrogen supplied as a
nitrogen fertilizer so
if you were applying a pound of nitrogen
as calcium nitrate
that has a positive
number um and it indicates that
uh for every pound of nitrogen applied
as that source uh that would have
equivalent reaction in the soil of 1.3
pounds of lime so not a a bunch of lime
but it certainly over time can affect uh
ph's soils
and then those with negative numbers uh
indicate that uh you would have to add
lyme to neutralize the acidity supplied
by those sources and
we'll talk about ammonium sulfate as
being a great nitrogen fertilizer for
blueberries well one one of the reasons
for that is it's so acidifying
for every pound of nitrogen you supply
is ammonium sulfate
you'd have to supply five pounds of
of lime just to neutralize the acidity
so
choosing these uh sources as
indicated
first cost per pound of nitrogen
secondly whether there's a need for
additional uh nutrients so the primary
issue there is is phosphorus so
that would be a reason to choose
ammonium
ammoniated uh phlosates
uh monoammonium or diamonian phosphate
whether you want to change uh soil ph in
which direction and then also
volatilization losses
so for uh blueberries uh the
materials
choice are um
urea if the ph is uh below five so if
it's below five you you want to maintain
it in that range you'd use the less
acidifying urea
you might also choose a
map or dap if the phosphorus is also low
and then we typically say if if the ph
is a little bit high and you'd like to
reduce it somewhat then ammonium sulfate
would be the choice there
and map and dap would again be good
choices if you are in need of phosphorus
for
brambles and strawberries
uh usually the cheapest forms are busts
so
urea or ammonium nitrate
are a good
choices there i know a number of growers
use
calcium nitrate
and there may be some
reasons for that particularly in the
middle of the summer when there's some
concern about
volatilization losses from uh from urea
so this volatilization uh aspect is
something that we primarily are
concerned about with urea and when you
apply
urea prills
to a soil surface the
first thing that happens to that peril
is hydrolysis so as it takes up water
that small organic uh
molecule of um urea
hydrolyzes and it produces uh ammonium
and bicarbonate
and uh the important aspect of this is
that this has an immediate effect of
increasing the ph around that prill or
in the immediate vicinity
so if
ammonium is present
near the soil surface under high ph
conditions then
it can be converted to ammonia gas and
lost to the atmosphere
so
part of the reason this is an issue with
urea is because of this ph increase that
you you get immediately after applying
urea
it's not to say that
ammonium
that's applied as say ammonium sulfate
can't volatilize it can also but in most
cases
ph of the soil is low enough uh to where
volatilization losses aren't a real big
deal
so what
increases the potential for um
volatilization losses of ammonia gas
well
first first off if the
urea particle remains on the soil
surface so if you don't irrigate it in
or you don't receive rain for several
days then that increases potential for
losses
if the temperatures are very high so if
they're above 80 degrees then that
increases the potential for losing more
of the
nitrogen in the urea and then as i
mentioned if the soil ph is high this
also increases potential for losses
so in the case of blueberries where soil
is uh
ph is is naturally
low
there's less likelihood of losing
nitrogen in the form of
ammonia gas
but it is something to consider in the
case of strawberries in particular where
we might be fertilizing in the middle of
the summer where the temperatures are
real hot
you'd want to make accommodations and
for reducing uh that potential and
usually that that means irrigating that
fertilizer into the soil to protect it
nitrogen rates so
applying the proper rate is
important as far as uh
optimizing the efficiency of nitrogen
used by any crop so if you apply more
than the crop crop needs you're
going to
have a lower use efficiency and you may
cause other problems as well
so rates vary from from state to state
and region to region and certainly due
to different soil types and what i have
here is just a
general range for nitrogen rates uh
starting from with blueberries
so you can see that uh we start with one
or two year old fields at 15 to 20
pounds of actual
per acre and then that's just ramped up
over time and then by the time you get
to
a mature
field you might be applying between 70
and 40 pounds of actual nitrogen to the
acre and the rates here
depend primarily on the soil type so the
sandier the soil lower the organic
content of the soil
the higher rate you would
probably need
nitrogen rates for uh brambles
uh here uh again starting somewhat lower
rate uh 20 to 40 pounds the first year
up to 30 to 60 pounds the second year
and then up to 50 to 100 pounds in the
third year and
in older plantings
so again the higher rates would be
applied on sandier soils and there's
some indication that
ball bearing
raspberries
would require higher rates than say
summer bearing raspberries and i think
this makes a little bit of sense if you
consider those
poor plants are cut down to the ground
each spring they're generating a whole
new stand of canes
as well as producing a crop of fruit all
in one
one season
so growers particularly on sandy or
ground will find that
rates even as high as 100 pounds may be
optimizing yield for fall bearing
raspberries
strawberries again these rates vary
somewhat from region to region but
generally we we think about 40 to 60
pounds of nitrogen
to the acre during the planting year
and then 50 to 100 pounds per acre
during the uh
production years so
um
these rates again are going to be
highest on the sandier soils
so
a little bit about rates but how about
timing
i think timing is a critical factor as
far as trying to optimize efficiency of
nitrogen use and in in michigan we we
feel that
a good system would be to apply
fertilizer in a split application so
half of it going on
about uh bed bud swell time before bloom
and then the second half of it going on
at uh
during pedal fall uh
perhaps three weeks later and what this
typically does
for us
is
provides
nitrogen available to the plants
during the
early
rapid growth flush from petal fall
through grown green
fruit
and then the second application later in
the season tends to
maintain adequate levels through the
harvest period
so you may find that it makes no
difference if you apply
nitrogen in one application or two
applications
if you're on a heavier soil or a soil
high in organic content
but i think you'll find
benefits from the split application
system particularly on the sandy or
sandier sites
and then the other
point i wanted to make that you're
probably aware of is that if you're
growing blueberries in
cold locations where winter injury is uh
is a concern
then applying nitrogen later than june
is is
should be avoided and the reason is it
tends to reduce uh hardiness of the
bushes going into the winter
so
if you're growing
hearty blueberries and a less
stressful
winter
location then you might be able to get
by with applying nitrogen a little bit
later in the season but
if you're growing blueberries where
you're just
stressed by the winter year after year
then this is where you want to be real
careful
about applying nitrogen or maintaining
high levels of available nitrogen later
in the season
a little bit about timing on brambles
here
what i would suggest is
if you're growing on heavier fertile
soils
probably do just as well applying all
your fertilizer at about bud break time
in april or may
if you're uh growing on sandy ground uh
that's low in organic matter
then you might go to this split
application approach where you're
applying half at uh
about bud break and then half three to
four weeks later
i think this will maintain levels of
nitrogen available to the plants later
into the growing season
and particularly with fall fruiting
types
support
of fruit production way out into
september and october
timing for uh perennial strawberries so
um
here uh
recommendations vary from the planting
year versus uh fruiting years
but during the planting year what we'd
typically recommend is 20 to 40 pounds
of nitrogen
two to three weeks after planting
you want to make sure that this is
delayed
to where
either irrigation or rain has settled
the soil around the plants
and then a second application
in august
so that would be
during a planting year
during
during a fruiting year
things change somewhat so here
we're recommending
applications of 30 to 50 pounds of
nitrogen
applied at
renovation time after harvest
and then about the same amount of
nitrogen applied in late august or early
september
there are some
some growers in
michigan i know that feel that they
need just a little bit of nitrogen
early in the spring of a fruiting year
and by a little bit i mean just 10
pounds or so
if they're growing on very sandy ground
this is i think kind of a a risky thing
to do because you can generate too much
vegetation by by
fertilizing in in the spring but if over
time you find that that works for you on
your soil then that might be a
good approach as well
and then lastly nitrogen placement so
uh the issues uh here are really a
balance between trying to
put the fertilizer where it's available
to the plant
versus not concentrating the fertilizer
so much that you
create a
salt issue
and injure the plants
so with blueberries what would be a good
approach is
to um with young plants so in the first
or second year
apply in a either a two foot a two to
three foot wide
circle around each plant by hand
or in a three to four foot wide band
down down the row
since these
bushes are usually at a 10-foot row
spacing if you're broadcasting
fertilizer over the entire surface
that's very inefficient
as the
bushes mature
you can imagine that the root system of
these old bushes uh
probably intertwines in between the
in between the rows
so here i don't think you get much
advantage from abandoning any fertilizer
within the row
and it's certainly easier to just
broadcast fertilizer and
older established uh
plantings
and we talked a little bit about
salt index in the earlier webinar
so this is a measure of
the
potential for causing salt stress
to plants
and i again wanted to reiterate that uh
you often see these uh salt index uh
values for different fertilizers and if
you consider these only
then you you'd steer away from ammonium
nitrate for example that has a very high
salt index and a high potential for
causing injury
and you might
look
more closely at calcium nitrate for
example that has a lower salt index
value
but these these values are based on
units of actual fertilizer so
if you're
working in the field of course you're
thinking about
i'm going to apply for example 50 pounds
of nitrogen what's the best source of
that well if you're using ammonium
nitrate that's higher in nitrogen
you would use less of that material
and so this last column is the salt
index
per unit of nitrogen and you can see
that the
numbers uh flip-flop so ammonium nitrate
might actually be more
safe to use on on younger plants than
calcium nitrate
another
aspect of this of course is it's easier
to hand apply
more diluted fertilizers such as calcium
nitrate than ammonium nitrate
nitrogen
placement and brambles kind of the
similar
thinking here as with the blueberries so
during the first year
you'd be either
applying it in a circle around each
plant
or again in a band
down each row
in established plantings you're kind of
to the situation where
you might be a little bit more efficient
by applying that in a band under the row
but in most cases growers are trying to
maintain a sod between the rows so in
order to fertilize the sod and fertilize
the raspberries it might be a better
choice to broadcast under those
circumstances
and then nitrogen placement in
strawberries and perennial strawberries
again during the planting year
generally you're probably broadcasting
fertilizer because of the close row
spacing i guess you could consider
banding in a smaller uh planting and
certainly uh broadcasting
when the plants are mature
here eric there's two questions on the
timing
uh that we have uh one was from kathy
and i think
kathy you might have to jump in to
clarify uh what you were looking at
there
and then uh
yeah eric i was wondering when you said
um
nitrogen and blueberry shouldn't be
applied after june if that was the
middle of june the end of june
i was hoping to clarify that just a
little thanks
this is a rule of thumb i'd say no
fertilizer after the first of july
so
make sure everything goes on
before july
and i'm looking for
the
box of uh
other questions was
was there another question besides that
kathy
go ahead dan
yeah eric it's it's in the uh chat box
so our folks over at oneida county
wanted to know
what's the right timing for nitrogen and
ever-bearing strawberries
yeah
ever bearing strawberries i haven't had
a whole lot of experience with but
typically
your those are on plastic
so you're fertigating
and the
timing
there
would be
more of a spoon-feeding approach through
the growing season
i think what there's some real good
information from
north carolina state university
uh for
plastic culture strawberry systems and i
think i'd
suggest you take a look at that
information but in general you're trying
to
grow a canopy uh throughout the
season and then to maintain
uh fruiting
uh for an extended period of
time
if it's the first
planting year on
ever bearing strawberries then you're
fruiting from august september and
october so that's a long period of time
you need to supply
nutrition during that time
and then typically under our conditions
growers are trying to overwinter those
beds
for fruiting the following uh spring as
well uh so if you're fruit i would
assume if you fertilize them
well uh through the previous uh year
that you probably would not require too
much
in the spring prior to that
that
june june cropping
i hope that
that answers that
and then there are um
wanted to mention organic sources of
of nitrogen
uh and
we talked about this a little bit in the
previous uh webinar but there are a
number of materials
that to choose from here a number of uh
different plant product and animal
product
materials so soy meal cotton
seed meal blood meal fish meal those are
relatively high in nitrogen
and they
release and make available a relatively
high percentage
of nitrogen content during the first
year
if you're using
manures
these
as we mentioned before should be
analyzed before you're using those but
typically they contain lower nitrogen
concentrations
and
and release a lower percentage of
nitrogen to the crop during the course
of the first year
and then compost of course are aged and
decomposed
usually plant materials
they contain
lower nitrogen concentrations as a
result
and they tend to be somewhat stable
because they're aged and they tend to
release a lower percentage of their
nitrogen during the course of the first
season
so those are generalities but i think
good rule of thumb is these products
with higher nitrogen contents usually
mineralize
higher
percentages of the nitrogen
during the course of the first year and
then
any compost or aged manures for example
tend to be more stable and tend to
mineralize and make available lower
percentages of the nitrogen during the
course of one year
it's a question uh is it risky using um
fresh manure and that's a
great comment so
during production
years if you're using fresh manure this
should go on
the year prior
after harvest
and in some with some crops
blueberries in
particular some marketers would advise
no fresh manure ever being used in
plantings
thanks for that link
dan
we've done a little bit of work with
nitrogen release from organic sources
and organic blueberries in michigan and
i wanted to show you some of those data
just because they illustrate kind of the
release pattern
for some of these
organic
fertilizers
so
um these are
the same material but two different
rates so this mcgeary's
soy-based uh
8-1-1 organic fertilizer was applied
may
10th and then we simply uh
watch the total inorganic nitrogen so
the ammonium and the nitrate levels and
the
soil profile
after application so you can see that
there was a pretty immediate release of
available nitrogen
and it tended to decline as the season
progressed but particularly at the
higher rate there was still a
elevated level of available nitrogen
in the
middle to end of september
during this
study
so there were no differences in nitrogen
levels in the blueberry
bushes but it does illustrate that
these
at least this material tends to release
nitrogen
on a gradual basis
that tends to mimic i think pretty
closely the nitrogen demand by by the
blueberries
and here here are some other similar
data from a different blueberry field
so here we just use one rate of this
particular nitrogen fertilizer
and it was applied at this uh point in
time and you can see that
immediately there was a increase in
available uh nitrogen um
uh from the fertilizer
levels declined but again even uh
towards the end of september levels in
the soil were
elevated over
plots with receiving no fertilizer at
all
so this
presents
a little bit of a concern about how you
fertilize organic blueberries
without
elevating
levels of available nitrogen
late in the season when we would like
those plants to be slowing down and
getting ready for for winter
and we've seen in two of these trials uh
increase in
the
level of bud damage during the winter
because
i think of this elevated levels
available nitrogen later in the season
the
use of potassium so
here
most of these crops have a fairly high
demand for potassium
and
fields often require regular
applications potassium
perhaps not annually but
often on a regular
basis
and the fertilizer
choices really should be based on
of course whether you're growing
conventionally organic
the cost per unit of
k2o
whether you need other
nutrients that might be in the
fertilizer and then a potential hazard
from chloride so i'll talk a little bit
about that
so
the cost per unit is cheapest for
potassium
chloride potassium sulfate is somewhat
higher
cost
and potassium magnesium sulfate or soap
mag
is even higher
cost per unit of potassium
the
potential problems with potassium
chloride or myriad is that it contains
chloride which in high enough
concentrations can
damage
berry crops
organic sources there are organic
sources of soap mag
of potassium sulfate as well this is a
different material than than this in
that it's apparently less processed so
it's uh
usable
organically and then of course wood ash
contains a fair amount of
potassium but it's very alkaline so if
if that's being used in blueberries in
particular
it would have a
effect of increasing soil ph
so rates of potassium for existing
plantings
usually
if a
deficiency exists
a hundred to 200 pounds of k2o
per acre will correct those shortages
growers over time that find that they
need maintenance applications of
potassium find that 50 to 100 pounds per
acre is adequate to do that job
the timing isn't as critical as it is
with nitrogen because
partly because
potassium moves in the soil but much
more slowly than nitrogen so getting it
on at the right time is not so critical
one point i'd make is that fall
applications would be
uh preferred if you're using the cheaper
myriad of potash
so that that would allow more time for
chloride to leach out of the root zone
before plants begin growing in the
the following spring
and it certainly would be the case if
you were applying a relatively high rate
of potassium say 100 pounds of k2o
or higher
and you wanted to use muriat that would
certainly be best applied in the fall
keep in mind that excessive use of
potassium can cause magnesium shortages
so i think marvin covered this pretty
well
previously in that there's a balance
between
the cations and soils calcium magnesium
and potassium
and if you continually apply potassium
because you think that you need it every
year you can cause trouble uh with
inadequate
availability of magnesium to the plants
there's a question how late in the fall
can you apply potassium
it's like i say it is going to stay in
the root zone
over
quite a few months
so i
you could apply it
any time in the late fall that potassium
should be available to the plants the
following spring
and the potassium
fall application would allow this
time for chloride to leach out of the
zone
phosphorus sources
nothing real striking here there are a
number of different materials to choose
from
conventionally
they all
are very highly soluble and highly
available to
berry crops
if you have a need for phosphorus and
the ammonia phosphates
would be a
good choices but if you're only
interested in
uh
phosphate uh then these are expensive
sources of them
for organic producers bone meal fish
meal
are good sources
rock phosphate isn't used too much but
i mentioned it because in
very acidic soils such as blueberry
soils the solubility is quite a bit
higher
so it might be a reasonable source of
phosphate
for blueberries where the
acidic
soil ph
increases the solubility of the material
a question about a good question a
common question about the use of
potassium in
in the fall as an antifreeze or to
increase the hardiness of bushes
and i haven't seen any
data to support that i
heard it from a number of
blueberry growers in particular
and there are some growers in michigan
that actually apply full year
applications of potassium in the fall
thinking that in
it helps to slow down the bushes and get
them ready for winter
uh it that may be true but i can't say
there's any scientific evidence that
that's true
something that probably is worth
investigating
and i um along those lines i think if if
you're working with growers and that a
question comes up
or a grower indicates that i do this and
it
does good for me
you might suggest to them
to leave some untreated check areas
so that they can actually learn
what the treatment did versus what they
think it did
magnesium and
calcium
here
sources
vary from magnesium sulfate epsom salts
calcium sulfate or gypsum
potassium magnesium sulfate
and then calcitic or dolomitic
lime
so typically at least under our soil
conditions in michigan if if we're low
in magnesium
and or
calcium it nearly always
indicates that the ph is too low
so the
correction would be to apply
either
a calcitic or dolomitic lime under our
conditions
there we tend to have
more of an abundance of calcium relative
to
magnesium in the soil so dolomitic lime
usually is a better choice but the soil
tests will tell you that
if the ph
is appropriate then
a source of
calcium might be gypsum epsom salts or
soapo mag would be good sources of
magnesium
like i say i i think that's fairly
uncommon to see
very low levels of magnesium or calcium
in a soil with a proper ph
calcium and fruit quality is
something that generates a whole lot of
attention and interest and for good
reason because
uh elevated uh calcium concentrations
and fruit tissue are often
associated with improved quality and
quality is such such an important uh
uh variable in in very crop production
so
we know uh
for example that uh
there's a reduced incidence of some
physiological disorders of fruits uh if
uh
calcium levels can be increased so
bitter pit
is a localized deficiency of calcium in
in apple fruit
so that's a um a fruit quality related
uh aspect
we know that uh there's an increase in
firmness uh usually that accompanies
increase in fruit uh calcium
concentration so this may uh relate to
the inhibitory effect of calcium on some
of the natural enzymes in in fruit that
are associated with the softening and
degradation of cell walls and
the natural
senescence of fruit
so calcium has a direct effect there
and then
there's also a reduction in
rot that's caused by several fungal
pathogens
and this may also go back to the
inhibitory effect of high calcium
concentrations on
some of those enzymes that originate
from the fungus
that
contribute to breakdown of the of the
tissue
so all good reasons to think about
calcium applications for improving
uh berry quality but what's known there
well
we know that
in increasing calcium levels and berries
can improve the the quality of berries
and we know that from the fact that if
you dip
strawberries or blueberries in calcium
solutions after harvest that increases
firmness in it
and or it increa reduces
the rot incidence
of course dipping these berries in
solutions doesn't have much commercial
utility because it has quality issues in
its uh
in itself but it does illustrate that if
you had ways of increasing calcium
concentrations in the in the berries
you'd probably see some benefit from it
so
the most likely approach to increasing
calcium levels in the berries is to
spray the plants with calcium sprays
prior to harvest
and there's been a number of studies in
different parts of the world on on these
three
groups of berries blueberries and
strawberries and
brambles
and calcium sprays have sometimes
increased firmness
and prolong the shelf life of berries
and or reduce botrytis rot
but i think the most consistent thing
about
these studies is the inconsistency so
these effects are seen sometimes uh and
they're not seen other times uh so
this is another one where there's no
clear um
answer for growers i'd advise people if
they're interested in
working with calcium sprays again go
back to that
rule of thumb try to try to make sure
that you're leaving untreated areas so
that you can tell whether your your
treatment actually did did some good
um another approach of course to
increasing levels of calcium in the
berries would be to
supply it through the roots so
this also hasn't been particularly
effective
uh these are some
data
that we collected on a low calcium
blueberry soil
years ago
in in michigan so we we selected the
site because it was low in calcium
and then we applied uh either a thousand
pounds of lime or 500 pounds of gypsum
each year for a number of years and you
can see that this had a very dramatic
effect particularly with the application
of lime of increasing the calcium
concentrations in the
in the soil
somewhat lesser uh
degree with the the use of gypsum
uh but
what we found from a quality standpoint
is that
these modest rates of lyme and gypsum
raised the ph and calcium levels of the
soil but had inconsistent effects on
on the leaf calcium levels
and in two years when we measured them
had no effect on fruit calcium levels
so they seem to get calcium somewhat
into the plant
but they
did not get uh
elevate calcium levels in the fruit
themselves which is where we we want it
and the treatments as a real result had
no effect on fruit yield or the shelf
life or the firmness
so i i thought this was a good test to
talk about here because
it was in a field that was low in
calcium to begin with and over time we
were able to pretty dramatically
increase calcium levels in in the soil
but this had pretty minor effects if any
on
calcium levels in the
in the plants and particularly in the
fruit where you'd like it
boron
is
interesting
micronutrient
and it can uh become deficient in uh
berry crops
uh generally if there's a shortage it
causes uh poor shoe growth and dieback
or reduced fruit set or sometimes fruit
deformities so these blueberry pitchers
were supplied by a
colleague in italy where they were
working with a
elliott site and
it
was extremely low in leaf boron levels
down to eight to ten parts per million
uh they had these uh lesions developing
on some of the uh
fruit these corky lesions and those were
corrected by boron applications
there was a question is there a
synergistic effect of calcium
on nitrate updrake when applied as
calcium nitrate
and i it's a good question and i
don't know as i have a good answer
to it
so
calcium nitrate of course because you're
applying
only nitrate
can be
relatively efficient if it's not leached
out of the root zone quickly
or it may be very inefficient if
if you're irrigating heavily after
applications or you receive a two or
three inch rain after your application
that will remove it all
and i don't know that of any specific
effects of calcium on uptake of
nitrate in particular
getting back to boron though
i wanted to mention that berries like
most crops are very sensitive to
excessive boron
so
applications should be made only if a
soil or soil or leaf analysis indicate a
need
so applying boron because somebody told
you that
it may correct to form berries is a
poor approach if you don't have
some data on boron levels in the soil
and
more importantly in the in the leaves
if
there is a need
it's easy to get boron into these crops
either through fullier applications
applied in early in the season
to the foliage or through sprays
to the ground in the spring that could
be applied with a
weed spray
or even soil applications of granulated
material in the in the spring
iron deficiencies occur periodically but
these are nearly always related to
a ph that's too high so
most common
occurrence of course is in blueberries
where the ph if the ph is above about
5.5 under our conditions we start to see
this sclerosis due to
iron
deficiency or
uh
occasionally uh in uh um
bramble or uh strawberry fields if ph is
very high you can get this similar uh
symptoms
so the the problem is really related to
effect of
ph and
dropping the ph is only a good solution
to it there are a number of foliar
iron chelated products available and
those do
provide some leaf greening
if they're applied to affected bushes
but
i question whether you really see an
improvement in the vigor
from those treatments i think sometimes
it's more of a cosmetic effect
manganese
this is another micronutrient that
where uh deficiencies can occur in
berries in the midwest and uh from what
i read they're they're probably even
less common in the in the northeast
and partly because it
again is usually
uh ph related
so if the ph is too high this limits a
solubility of manganese
and
can cause deficiencies of magnesium
of manganese and the reason that
blueberries of course
seldom run into manganese uh deficiency
is that the
ph is low so it
increases availability of that
micronutrient
so if
there's a need for manganese check ph
and reduce it
uh if there's
if it's too high
there are four sprays of manganese
sulfate
manganese chelates
can be used
some
fungicides contain significant amounts
of manganese and those are pretty good
sources also for
labeled crops
zinc
similar to manganese
we see deficiencies occasionally in
berries in midwest and i think that
occurs also in the northeast
and shortages again are typically occur
in soils that are
sandy and too alkaline too high in ph
treatments here uh again check the ph
reduce it if it's too high
uh you can apply foliar sprays of zinc
sulfate or zinc chelate products if the
ph is appropriate
and there are some fungicides that
contain zinc that can be reasonable
sources for
labeled
crops
yeah and question does manganese have
some fungicidal properties itself
uh similar to copper i don't
know that that's the case um
good good question i wish i could answer
it
uh copper and molybdenum
uh these uh soils in the midwest and
northeast uh appear to supply adequate
levels of these micronutrients to
berries
and uh because deficiencies haven't
really been documented
a uh colleague at uh
in georgia indicates that rabbit eye
blueberries in
those areas uh occasionally are
deficient in copper
uh and he indicates symptoms include
abnormally small leaves and and short
or shoot die back during the uh during
the winter
but i don't know that that that's this
has
occurred in
northern high bush in
midwest to northeast
and again there are fixed copper
fungicides that are suitable sources
copper
salts can potentially injure tissues so
uh this is something that should be
used with uh with caution
but again copper and molybdenum uh
rarely if ever deficient under our
conditions
uh and then lastly i wanted to mention
fertigation
and this is of course the injection of
fertilizers through trickle irrigation
systems and the reason this is
appealing is it's so convenient
and it's a way of increasing the
efficiency of fertilizer use
so for berries in the ground fertigation
is most useful for delivering nitrogen
and sometimes potassium or phosphorus so
the big advantages are greater control
over uh nutrient placement and timing
and as a result improved efficiency
so less fertilizer may be required
uh but there are some caveats to that
and then disadvantages of course are
there there's capital investments in
injector and tanks and backflow valves
and such
and then there's some maintenance and
management
costs involved in this as well
and many of these typical fertilizers
very soluble
so
ammonium nitrate ammonium sulfate
calcium nitrate
very high solubility
potassium
materials are somewhat lower in
solubility
these solubility levels are pounds of
product per per gallon
so they're extremely high
16 pounds per
per gallon is uh
extremely high solubility i wanted to
mention that uh these levels are all
measured at the
70 degree water and solubility of all
the materials is lower the colder the
water gets so if you're using well water
you may find that this is uh
water will take maybe half as much
of these materials as you can get into
solution at 70 degrees
as uh
one precaution uh is
don't mix
calcium with sulfates or phosphates
so as if you're mixing up batch
solutions for fertigation
this is a
general rule of thumb that
these will
cause precipitation
uh and plugging problems as a result
and you're all probably familiar with a
jar test so you can always take
proportions of these materials and mix
them up in a jar to
test for
mixtures and concentrations that result
in precipitation
the fertigation
for
blueberries and brambles some general
thoughts first i think if you're new to
this you can probably reduce your annual
rate by about a third
so that's assuming there's improved
efficiency
and what i would start with is
to split that annual rate
into multiple applications
uh two to three weeks uh beginning uh
two to three weeks after bud break and
continuing through
july for blueberries and into august for
for brambles so that's that's kind of
a general
you can fertigate a
weekly or every two weeks
or you can
fertigate every time you irrigate
generally i think the efficiency that
you gain
you would gain
that would be gained from a split
application with three or four
application dates
you probably wouldn't
improve on that too much by even
continual fertigation
so
fertigation can be very efficient uh
assuming that first your irrigation
system has high uniformity
so in the midwest and the northeast
we're usually irrigating to supplement
uh
precipitation
so if your irrigation system's not
particularly uniform it's not
uh such a big deal
but if you're supplying all your
nutrition through that irrigation in the
uniform uniformity is poor then that
becomes a bigger deal
nutrients are applied when uh demand is
high so if you're uh fertigating and
you're applying
uh nutrients before bud break before the
bushes are able to
utilize nutrients then
you probably won't be achieving the
efficiency that you you could be
if you're applying them when the demand
is highest
and then uh
uh also assuming that plants are not
over irrigated
so
if you're uh
irrigating uh and pulsing uh fertilizer
through the system
and then you're
irrigating heavily afterwards it's very
easy to push that nitrogen down through
the profile and out of reach of the the
plants this was just a ditch dug across
a raspberry row
under a high tunnel so this is the
trickle irrigation system
and just
illustrate if if you
deliver your nitrogen where you should
deliver it
and then you over furl over irrigate
after that it's very easy to push it
down below
the rooting system of the the crop so
here again you'd lose the efficiency
that you might have gained
and a question about any economic
analyses of uh fertigation that's a
great question i don't know of any uh
per se
i
yeah i can't really think of any
uh something that would be useful if it
were available
so we're just about out of time and i
wanted to thank uh
marvin and kathy in particular for uh
organizing this webinar series i think
it's been real real good
so are there any um closing questions or
particularly comments
anything you'd like to discuss further
a question uh what guidelines for
irrigation uh frequency
an inch per week in summer
for example
i think each um
i would go to um
the strawberry blueberry and raspberry
uh production guides out of cornell i
think they
those publications do a great job of
summarizing that information in
detail you know in
blueberries and raspberries in michigan
we always talk about an inch of water
per week through the uh
through the season as a
rule of thumb but i think you can
generally do quite a bit better
than that if you have a little bit more
information available
question generally when blueberries are
mulch they say
to increase nitrogen rates a little
but doesn't that and get released
eventually as the mulch breaks down
or does it disappear that's another
great uh question you know in a
perennial cropping system like that
over time you would uh eventually get to
uh
equilibrium equilibrium where your
the nitrogen supplied the prior year
will be partly released and
through microbial
decomposition of the
older materials so
you're right that if you're applying a
fresh comp uh mulch over underneath the
blueberries
that effect on nitrogen availability
really is during the first year
after that you may find that you can go
back to a
rate that is consistent with a site that
didn't have mulch applied to it
now in reality a lot of growers would be
applying mulch every second third or
fourth
year so you'd have to make those
adjustments over time
bob is asking have you seen times where
applications of nitrogen
are
accidentally doubled or tripled
i
i'd probably have seen those but i
haven't known them at the time
with blueberries in particular what's
striking to me is how
slow they are to react to
fertility
so when we've done
fertilizer trials where some of the
treatments get a high rate of nitrogen
some of them get no
nitrogen
it often takes two or three or even four
years before you see a response in the
bushes
so
with these perennial plants like
blueberries and probably to some extent
raspberries
they tend to respond slowly
to good things and bad things
um
yeah charlie was asking cranberries
uh
also
uh and i assume you're asking about uh
um response to nitrogen
uh cranberries are quite a bit more
responsive to nitrogen than blueberries
so what you do in a particular year
you'll see the response to that year
yeah and a question uh um
would a cover crop
be helpful in
tying up some of the excess nitrogen
late in the season and that that's a
great uh point and it's absolutely true
so in michigan a lot of
a standard cover cropping system is
august or september seeded annual rye
and i think part of the benefit of that
rye is it tends to
soak up some of the excessive
fertility in the soil and perhaps make
that available the next spring so good
good point
i think
kathy's saying thank you so we're gonna
sign off here is that what that means
kathy
thanks so much for your attention
and uh thank you eric for
joining us today uh we'll be
we have another webinar next week
uh and kathy i'll be uh sending out uh
information on that
uh
during the week
so have a good day everyone
thanks again eric and dan talk to you
all next week